my name is sebastian a
software engineer google in the work on
spey google logo gps receiver cent
here is a window into the open ab
you can't say that after the ten most of
the talk ab is next there flee in the
sections forester second  the highlevel
overview on the system the second ran
timing and anything you are in the
second part focus and when particle
aspect into the penthouse atomic clock are
two men and systems has google big
table and megastore ecological compact
able to be consistent models application
packaging
the application about  900 kerbersdorf in
the 2 founded google live too much time
spent on getting the action means julian
frank joecks girlfriend post about to
your friends or in front of the door to the door
data centers email or post
peters that is the beginning and the sams in the
big table didn  't have never stop and we
have it max program in much easier
the high level system overview
layout set to send collerone feature
artikel.de knows that  layout of the best photo
applications album are photos ens
advertising sandwich chain photos table of the
primaries is emerging extension of the
album state scenario knows physics winter
ran the russian store database and i
have a computer to enjoy it systems
joints liability get together data
from different parts  of the world with
the flow and even a gps receiver
software problem
as well as well-known ski space man when bp
space and that in the green goes to
start a database develop news the
starts necessary server sap waste and
scale up to really latsch databases here
exactly like invisible locations  as well as
single charts as well as managed applications
of this morning practice implementation is
actually monastery to solve because youtube
in practice page along lift leaders
and and both of the players and any
time list leader and advanced traction
manager and top of the dead trade
transactions loks in  the braker data
center for example
looking at the physical serving
structure  s and when data center the
bunch of service recall in the spam service
the post this tablet so individual
replicas of charge server password
upper flow of the tablet the son master
degree balances tablets between service
model cities granieri the on the charts
of the tablet is much smaller the
pun  and single server of the
user to quickly barron's according to between service
at a little bit of the data for one
server and lodging defense server mating
son march who looks like a single point
of failure in disentis at the
northern Bavarian ports because it
balances away load and client server  talk
directly to the sun master monitor
individuals and the hot standby
middle blocker of the architect single
data center security okay here comes the
high level victim as well as the system that
values ​​itself today focus on
transactions and commodities
[music]
20 h blockx you pick your comes  time
stamp in front of the wide because you know you're
dead in a case that means we are two
taxis sow  ie replicator at least with
south africas in wanfried quorum uk
complete to you can tell de client here
determines your data and youth theater
replicas des data is committed to the
conflict of the order and its first and
only ones we can get the box and that
can get much  earlier in the times
underdogs on the time line indications
executed
in one on one more thing to point out in
the know how as before how effectively suffers
local problems concentrated so client
right thing now the air force and
immediately turn so was and the circle
talks talks  now the crickets to
researchers of the brit aqualux which means
that needs will block reiters so that
in de facto database for your right to
speak because of the wait for the sweet
in olso weblog behind reiters so it is
so far in progressive knowledge to
client software to technology  des juli
used in the data base community is
called multiversum bankruptcy isla dir is
yu on the keyboard versions of you get
around for a while some p  oint in gabis
collectors ultimately norbert from
outside versions of the date you can
take the protection suite in the order
of armament exports the juve prefix on
the comet history so is napoli content
twenty twenty four for example
seat of the forest klopstock am see you get
this consistent snapshots  in the
systems lab discipline shot of some nice
properties der in jubilation in the
consistency that makes it very easy for
thought we can use them for crm suite
enjoy before long running for example
mapreduce der brit holt database and
round up your money for example the
important  for say if this is possible
your costs should the magic band
transfers money for one account to
produce would like you the impact on
going transactions and method you know
it will own accounts in the robot
men pull german balance sheet exactly
to jesus before by norman reach  for
example the wall street where you say
okay is discover.de that may be used
for that you can offers hi  erbei replica
depressive
snapshot correspondence
the trick is the optics of the comet time
stands in order to get this meaningful
snapshots a last thing first video
with times teams from the server local
club scene by calling you can't slow
down the clock in think again service
pointed  nabu at the samsung group company
is the way business one take away the
words that people we spent money for
less joke before in the this change so
open so just in the us is fine way to
cable wakeboard peopleclick and heart and
costs as well as the import  and because with
somebody clicks on he has the
hypothetical company that man and since
the mini clicks like when the all over
the world of the computer or click
the atlantic buggy can do that at
essential jupiters pointed first first
party and now you can you take that
split  point and wedels forester in the
second harvest
now you can do the following scenario
alex boxes you're strange fruit
attraction the great work song u  s-server
the service system is a place of celebration of
his ipad is since the fact and search
query surfs the earth user husen europe
the user clicks on the kind of
klitschkos comeback of the server and as
in saxony does and the costs fully
had the europe with  it in a european
tae bo do not is this tut transactions
the conflict musicians completely
different tables a fact of
the server in the server is the dealer
server concessions service system is
norbert essing industrial state in the
browser user clicks sonnet browser sense
back to the server becomes  the starts of
saxon thum
in time to be realized that is in a
transaction history in the base in
maryland is the english foreclosure
contains transaction two steps for local
server stynes ​​dies clogs an perfect
resize possible that the service 16
be style in transaction tour
d'  amour lia time stamp and the waves
should of the system is support teams
times online blog sector clock so
saturday requi  res is the tube as long as
control of time on every message in the
receiver can say goodbye update my time
to or at least your way you lie force
that is in nasty boards in the in
latsch of the cooling system it's impossible to tag
the semester long remember  the steps
wiwo.de sends service systems
embedded in such in the browsers
superclix center times der back to serve
the ways to make space for something say
new include the phone call check out my
new something you can't in bed times
phone cards together friends autoview
control and so that's who time
synchronization camps came it just now
is the bug first squad property the
relevant and sometimes sad external
consistent you yes so linear quiet
pill under the definition israeli
transaction comic action committee for
transaction to start the conviction and
released  to realize before it and in
other words pours comet temple of
the motto there is the property so we
had since you of the root egg  n global
time like mr bauer
interviews time it could be that is the
labels part with continents real time
life somewhere in the interval at which
don't know exactly where they think
about this is the early stage at least
for you for the music client  and
external definition
so ist wie vor transition to start
veolia concessions once it's time stamp
is in the past introduction to starts
now time stamp of millions of users
pilot shortened property dort zu hessen
interesting property that you can always
the strong retweet at peking july time
stamp  the snapshot gives birth to times and
that the future the trend is you have
something that has been committed
already because this time stamp is supposed to be in
the past the little bit and the promised
actually up-to-date upgrade 31 that
would have gps receiver the muslim gps
receiver with  the lifetime of something
so that the safe and you never sleeps
second fiasco del have the organic farmers
gps receiver safe drinking and economics
of acti  ng ready
singing circle of the gps receiver so now cover
meanwhile is sünkel ice cover gardens idea
of ​​what i'm interviews live dates
receiver los in sun city fans with the
act of ex love round trip pressure grows
here surfing tigers and nutritious
cologne to the interview in the  new jazz blues
the foreword is a passage based on what
your local clock is a perfect match
liga del with tattoos relaxed hardware
specs server you can you know how much
stay gold master hedge fund
central europe and different so over time to
time interview big fight until next
synchronization  would have to part masters
so got smile again in slowly big
big overtime
so i got the place pattern
essentials of your time uncertainty yes
that is a bad thing is implemented in the
data center scout and low gps
receiver in evry server edition for data
center overall are revealed service
booklet elliot  clock so conservative
contractor services to run will
microsoft meets rating gps measured the
high school diploma  the secondos so gives a
uncertainties leaves and every second
news service and i feel you spend a
couple of extra wax and beta blocker
servers you can get the way down
that brings me to the endorphins
talk just in time to want dix on the
computer but first class risk
movement starts at ebay support
transactions hub program applications
with cars baby des brokers applications
that needs it but most of the time the
problems and start with strong semantic
sketch application light and only if you
really need it may be relax dies
semantics 62 complex distributed to face
minutes slow as possible to rod stewart granger surf tablet playbook
tablets the implementation of breaking
up in the first thing hier oder hier
case we get the [ __ ] is like the
previous talk mit making and so i turned
out the dictateam had to article logic
at least three  times the costumes is
bugs in the show tab including heinz after
years of huge insam obscure holidays case
with certain kom  bination of prussia stress
tests that still has to cost the
big table team is jupiter and engineers
text to speech applications to sin an
likely person donald rumsfeld rescued
annes know how much of you think you for
your time and quite some time for
questions to cover
kiowa hobby  meschede build but
blocked the best hardware specs to date
board so best moderator of a
hardware is like know how much is shot
of [ __ ] bf if we place in the
scientific the place to be and hey you
actually build in bad there juli flew at the
monastery and potenter  on tour
samsung slumped the reflex machine and sent to
repair schloss am see so that the chain
sway before it actually becomes well at
inter like pharmacies
question is how much to this blogs
social content that question please
don't know what the expensive completely
too long  big data center
the new session
yes yes the questions about holidays
scenarios advantage masters john hemming
julian having the bold a masters  from
multi boutique sources and gps
receiver for more than one company
exchange eex client synchronous times
that the exagon single just one of the
things with several of the forgotten and
its watchers angelina jolie
sing together rejects lions or weekend this
case of second were some truth software
starbucks and jump back to the very
large scale system test who bunch of
clients hammer the system need three
cents record audiences and doing the
test project lot of sales network
british secret service paas school
holidays sectors like fatime cindys
uncertain the interviews in the the
changed test rejected oldies loxley
major final sales systems
recovery cases growth tests of
the samples bugs at the evans likely to
production stress tests support defense
village siko and is actually ended 1 1
expect that time is especially the
uncertainty doubt that you have atmos so
that user lets intelligence and because
the application servers  of data centers
and indifferent  data center steven
defour holender goes down like don't use
any data base tab occasion on tugged the
big professes contact gt masters before because
for example the way back schlitters and
herbert even to answer faster comes in
the documentation
[applause]